sinon toi tu as compris le court qu'on a
fait ce matin par exemple puisque entre
la cathode et de l'année à seulement 14
ans odyssée passent le bac cette année
c'est l'une des plus jeunes candidats de
france 3 en avance par rapport à ses
camarades ça va il a assez bien
expliquer la différence entre absorption
et émissions mais après là j'essaye de
prendre les marques un peu tout seul de
voir d'autres gens et c'est pour trouver
et des vrais alliés puis pas que ce soit
d'autre kim en face elle est même mieux
sur certains cours que moi même
par exemple en physique est peut-être un
peu mieux que moi j'y suis quoi elles
portent en jeu plus vieille qu'elle
reconnu personnes à très haut potentiel
intellectuel odyssée n'aime pas sans lui
ce week-end elle est remplie par des
compétitions de badminton et m'écoutent
obtenus lors des derniers championnats
régionaux celles-ci un mixtape mon
partenaire délais courts et des podiums
de prestigieux concours comme miss
france ce jour à avoir ce cette espèce
de challenge de me dire que oui là ok
j'ai peut-être perdu jour là mais la
prochaine fois faut que je gagne enfin
c'est un défi personnel même dire que
oui je peux je peux y arriver je dois me
donner les moyens de rue
[Applaudissements]
il
corinne sa maman est sans aucun doute sa
fan la plus fidèle qui ne renonce à
aucun défi des fois on est confronté à
des problèmes administratifs comme la
pour les études supérieures l'année
prochaine où on a besoin de documents
comme carte vitale et tout ça et j'ai
demandé des dérogations parce qu'elle
n'a pas l'âge ont fait à chaque fois
pour ça marche dans quelques mois
odyssey s'envolera pour besançon les
grandes études dans l'espoir de devenir
criminologue et en attendant direction
mulhouse pour les championnats de france
de bad linde